hey everyone it's an the--from pretty
pretty here in today's video I'm going
to make what you see on the screen here
come alive so basically this app is
going to allow you to see the current
weather in various cities that you add
to the database using this little form
up here so I'll be creating this app in
Django and this is the template that I'm
going to be modifying to be dynamic
through Jenga so before I get started I
just want to let you know that I have a
free course on my website django
database essentials where you can learn
how to use various parts of the model
system in django you can check that out
after you watch this video on my website
at pretty pretty calm and if you don't
remember that address you can click on
the link in the description below so
I'll have a code for this video in the
description below as well including this
starting file and one other thing you
should know is we're going to use the
open weather map API so you'll have to
sign up for that if you want to work
along with me so I have an environment
setup already and I have a jangle
installed so what I'll do is I'll start
a project so Django let's see where's my
o Django admin start project now I'll
call this the weather not the most
creative name but that's what I have so
change into that directory and then I'll
start by creating an app as well so
python manage pi start app and I'll call
the app weather because whoops that's
not what I want it so start app weather
and I'll just delete the directory where
I messed up okay so the app is going to
be called weather because there's
absolutely going to do one thing which
is get the weather so the first thing
I'll do is I will open up the files so
I'll drag this into vs code and what
I'll do here is I will add the app to
the project so settings and I'll go over
to install apps and add weather just
like that and I'll be keeping all
of the other settings as the default and
then what I'll do is I'll create a super
user well I need some migrate first so
Python Manish top PI migrate and then
Python and manage top I create super
user Anthony will be the username pretty
printer calm it's email Oh in our
password okay so I have my super user so
what I'll do is I'll start up the app
just to make sure everything is working
correctly so I'll run the server go to
the page and go to the admin - for it
and make sure I can log in so username
Anthony and then password is going to be
password 11 with a capital P login okay
so everything there is fine so the next
thing I want to do is I want to get that
template into the project so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to cut this and
then paste it inside of the app I need
to create a directory called templates
and then inside of that directory
alcohol create a directory called
weather which matches the name of the
app and here I'll paste the weather
template in there so now I'll be able to
look at it here and we see that's
exactly what I want so the next thing I
want to do is I want to actually view
this page when I go to the index so for
right now when I go to the index I get
the congratulations page telling me that
Django has been or the project has
installed correctly so what I'll do is I
will first update the URLs here I'll add
another path for the index so I won't
put anything in there because I don't
want an additional endpoint and then
I'll use include which I have to import
from Django URLs so include and then I'm
going to include weather dot URLs which
is a file that I'm going to create in
just a second here so actually I'll use
this as a base
and then inside of my weather app I'll
create URLs dot pi and then I'll paste
that there and remove the things that
aren't necessary okay so now I'm going
to import all my views so from period
import views and I'm going to create a
view called index in a moment it doesn't
actually exist yet
but it will in just a second so view
index now I'll go to that views file and
create to that index view so takes in
requests of course and then I'm going to
return at that template so I need to
pass requests to render and I also need
to pass in the name of the template so
in this case the name is weather /
weather dot HTML so that should be
enough so if I go back here and it's my
app running it failed because I saved
before I created that euro rails file so
let's try it out again and now I can see
the template being rendered through my
app instead of just as a plain HTML file
so now what I want to do is I want to
make this kind of come alive so to do
that I'm going to call the API and let
me drag in the URL for this so looking
at the documentation here is an example
of the call so basically it's their URL
slash data slash the version and then
I'm looking for the weather and then the
query takes in the name of a city so
this example has London or you can pass
in the country as well so London comma
UK and also I want to use Fahrenheit as
the units but you can use Kelvin which
is the default or you can use Celsius if
you choose to do so but I'll be using
Fahrenheit for this tutorial so here
inside of the index I'll just put a URL
here as URL so this is just the API URL
so once you sign up for open weather
open weather map you'll get an API key
so you just pass that app ID into your
URL and you'll be able to access their
API if you don't pass them the API key
then you won't be able to access it here
you see I have units as imperial meaning
I will get Fahrenheit as the temperature
and then the queue here is actually a
placeholder because that is the city
that I'm going to query for so I'm going
to just set the city variable equal to
Las Vegas for now that's where I live
and later I'll make it pull from the
database but just to test things out
I'll set the city to be equal to Las
Vegas and now what I need to do is I
need to install request so I can
actually send a request to this URL so
I'm going to run pip in install and then
request I should only take a moment and
here I'll import it so import requests
and while that runs I'll just type in
requests get URL formats pass in the
city and then I'll assign this to BR are
short for response and what I'll do is
I'll print out our text meaning the
output of that response so if I run my
server again and if I go to my index
again it should run but I get an error
tells me that the request does not have
an attribute called gets and that's
because I didn't use the S on the end
there should be requests not requests so
let me run that again and it works so if
I go to my console I see the data here
that I'm looking for so I just printed
it out that's why we can see it here so
the next thing I want to do is I want to
pass this data to the template well I
want to pass the relevant data because a
lot of this data I won't be using but
there is some data that is pretty
important so basically looking at this I
need the name of the city I need the
temperature in Fahrenheit I need a
description of the weather and I need
the I
so the icon the temperature and the
description come from the API and then
the city of course comes from my app so
I will create a dictionary that
represents all of that information I'll
call this city whether it's going to be
a dictionary and for my request I'm
going to call dot Jason on this so it
converts the result of the request into
adjacent object or I should say it will
interpret the response as adjacent
object and convert it into a combination
of Python dictionaries and Python lists
so Jason objects can be easily
represented by dictionaries and lists in
Python so that's what Jason is doing so
there are four things that I said I want
I want the city I want the temperature I
want the description of the weather
there and finally I want the icon so the
icon is actually something that's hosted
on their site so as long as you supply
the right icon code then you will get
the correct icon
so these shouldn't be strings I'll
remove that and since I have this R here
that is what I want I'll take away that
print statement so R is now a Python
dictionary and the city is actually
coming from the city variable the
temperature is going to come from R and
then it's going to be main I believe so
let me look here I'm looking for a main
yeah and then inside of main I'm looking
for a temp so main and then temp and
then for the description this is a list
I believe so weather and then it's going
to be a list with one item in it so if I
go to weather where is weather here we
go so list with one item we see here the
description and clear sky so weather
first item in the list and then
description and that will give me the
description of
the current weather and then I want the
icon which is going to be pretty much
the same thing except for instead of
description I'm going to have the word
icon so now let me just print this out
to make sure everything looks okay and
refresh the page and my app doesn't want
to restart correctly so let me try that
again and run this and we see the
description has updated two broken
clouds the temperature is 88 point three
eight the city is Las Vegas and the icon
is zero for D so now let's pass all of
that information over to the template so
I'll remove the print statement I'll
create a context variable and I'll just
call this city weather and then I'll
pass in the actual dictionary there and
then I'll pass contacts to the template
open up the template and then I need to
replace the things that need to be
updated so in this particular case this
is going to be C a City weather dot city
so this is just using everything I
created in that dictionary so the
weather so city weather dots temperature
City underscore weather dots description
and then finally the icon here I have
the URL so basically you modify this
part in the URL to use the icon code so
city weather dots icon there we go so
now if i refresh the page this should be
a little different because it is not 29
degrees there are no thunderstorms right
now and it's not raining so if i refresh
this we see now we have the picture of
the Sun which means clear sky usually we
get the actual temperature 89
Oh point five six and then we have clear
sky as the description and of course the
city is the same because I'm using a
different City if I change this all I
need to change is one thing so instead
of Las Vegas is this as a city if I said
London and then I ran it it should give
me the weather for London so I get
London as the word here it's forty seven
point three nine degrees Fahrenheit in
London it's hazy and then it has this
picture of what I assume to be haze I've
never seen that kind of picture before
for weather but then again we've never
had haze in Las Vegas as a description
as far as I can remember so you can see
that just by changing the name of the
city everything else works because you
know you're calling the API with that
new city and then it's just simply
supplying that return data in this
dictionary and passing it to the
template so this is nice but this only
works for one city at a time if I want
to display multiple cities then I need a
way to one represent multiple cities and
to kind of loop over all those cities
and perform a request for each one to
get the weather for each city so to do
that I'm going to create a table in the
database and that table is going to be
very simple so let's go to models and
we'll call this city and the whole point
of this table is to allow me to store a
bunch of city names in the table so it's
going to have a single useful column so
named and then it's going to be a char
field and we'll give them max length as
25 and then I'll define a stir method on
it and we'll just return self dot name
and then finally I need to define a meta
class and this is just so the plural of
city will be cities with i es instead of
s so it's just a little visual thing
when you're using the admin dashboard so
that shows verbose underscore name
underscore plural just like that and
then I want this to be cities because by
default its cities like that but
to be correct so make the city's like
that so now what I need to do is I need
to make migrations and then I'm going to
migrate okay and now what I want to do
is I want to add this to the admin
dashboard so admins
dot sight register and then the name of
the model which I'll import from models
just like that and I'm going to run the
server so I can look at the admin
dashboard so python managed pi run
server and then i'll go to the admin
dashboard and i see cities here so what
I'll do now is out add a few cities Los
Angeles Tokyo and one more let's say
Melbourne if I can spell it correctly
there we go okay so three cities and now
what I want to do is I want to actually
query for those cities so if I go back
to the home page what I expect to see is
the weather for each of those three
cities that I have so to do that I need
to first query the database for all the
cities that I have so inside of views
here what I'll do is I'll just add the
query here so cities is going to be
equal to city objects all and of course
I need to import city from models or
from models import city and with the
cities now what I'm going to do is I'm
going to loop over it and do something
for each city so for for city in cities
I'm going to do something and that's
something that's actually the same thing
that I'm doing here so I'll just end int
everything so it goes inside of the loop
and what I want to do is I want to get
the weather for each city and appended
to Ali
so I'll call this lists weather data and
here at the bottom I'm going to append
this city weather dictionary that I
create for each city just like that so
what it's doing is it's going to loop
over all the cities that I have in the
database and for each one it's going to
query the API the data that gets
returned is going to be put into this
dictionary called City weather and that
city weather dictionary is going to be
appended to my weather data lists and
then it starts over and it kind of
starts from scratch with the next city
and it's going to pin that city to the
list so if I have three cities in the
database then this list that I have will
end up being a list of three elements so
once I have that
let me try printing this out so print
weather data so this won't work
correctly the first time but you see
it's just one city mail born but if I
look at the prints I see three things
inside of the lists and I see a minor
problem here it says the city is
actually an object instead of the name
of the city so that's an easy change if
I go here instead of city is going to be
city dot name because I don't want to
pass the object I once you pass the name
inside of the object that represents
each city just a minor difference there
the object is something that you work
with in python the name is something
that you're actually displaying to the
user so now instead of passing a city
weather
I'm going to pass weather data to the
template and then I'll go into my
template again and when I'm looping over
something like this I want to find out
where the HTML repeats because I want to
have that HTML be inside of my loop so
in this case it's the box that I need to
create multiple times so each city gets
its own box so for city in
whether data and you know just for
consistency purposes so I don't have to
change anything here I use the same
variable so for City weather in weather
data and then I need to find the end of
this box which is right here in four and
now if I run this it should work
correctly so now we see I have the three
cities that I'm interested in I can't
verify the weather in any of those
cities because I'm not there but you see
that is different for each one so in LA
at 75 degrees Tokyo 65 degrees in
Melbourne it is 70 and you see they all
have clear skies which is nice it's good
that there's nice weather all around the
world right now so the last major thing
that I want to do is I want to allow the
user to actually type in a city here and
add it that way I don't have to go into
the admin dashboard and at the cities
myself so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to go into my app and create a new
file called forms stop PI and inside of
forms I'm going to say from Django dot
forms import I want to import model form
because my form is basically the same as
the model so I'm only concerned with the
name of the city so I don't need to
create a custom form I can just create a
form based off that model and then I
know I need to import text input because
I need to do something with it and then
I'm going to say from models import city
and I'll go ahead and create the form so
class is going to be city form it's
going to be a model form and then I need
to define the metaclass so I can assign
the model to be city and then the fields
that I'm interested in our only name so
just one field and then I'll use text
input in a second when I show you what
goes wrong so now what I want to do is
I'll go back to views and now I have to
start thinking of the two cases that
I'll have when I'm doing this I'm going
to have a case where they are just
viewing the page and I'm going to have a
case where they are
saving a new cities of the database so
they're actually hitting the submit
button so in the case where they hit the
submit button what I want to do is I
want to save whatever they enter into
the database and then return the same
screen with basically the same
information so to do that
all I need to do is think about you know
weirder places logically so really the
main case that I'm concerned with is
when it's a post request everything else
is going to be the same after I save the
data so method or a request stop method
posts and then I'm going to do something
here
and I can take away the city by the way
because I'm no longer using that
directly so our input or our import from
forms import city form and what I want
to do is I'm going to instantiate this
form so a form equals city form and I'm
putting this under the if request method
egos posts because I want this form to
be blank even after they submit it so if
I set this to be in its own block where
you know it's a get requests then
anytime they submit a city it will leave
that city in the form when the page
reloads and that's not something I want
I want the form to kind of restart every
time they submit so that's why I'm doing
that here it may be a little confusing
when I explain it but if you actually
tried it in the code you'll discover
what I mean by this you'll see that it
doesn't reset the city so this is what
it looks like when I pass the form so a
form is form and then in the template
I'll find the form that I have so
basically it's just one single input and
this a should be a button so let me
update that and it's going to be type
submit so type submit just like that and
then I'm going to pass in the input from
jingle forms so form dots name
so let's take a look at that and I get
the input under my original one but it
doesn't look like my original one
because it's missing the class input and
the placeholder as well so that's why I
use the text widget here so I'll define
widgets here and by doing this
I'll get access to the widget for the
name so it's going to be a text input
and really all I want to do is add a
couple of attributes so one is the class
so the class is input and then one is
the placeholder the placeholder is going
to be let me copy a city name just like
that so I'll paste that there and then
I'll refresh take a look at it and we
see it now matches the style of the
original input so I'll remove the
original input because I won't be using
that one so let me just take that one
away and now I should be able to submit
my form and it tells me that CRS CSRF
verification failed so what I need to do
is I need to add the CRS see our SF
token just like that and then when I try
this again and I'm missing something
really obvious let me think about it for
just a second should have the token
there oh I spelled it it's Harper
announcing acronyms like that okay so
yeah CSRF not CRS F minor mistake okay
so we see the weather is changing a
little bit in these cities
I'm guessing clouds are just moving over
the cities that's why you see now
there's broken clouds and over classic
outs in those cities and if I submit the
form nothing happens but if I want to
see that data let's see
use I'm going to print requests dot
posts so now I'll just type in some
gibberish hit at city and now I see that
gibberish here that I typed in so now
the last thing I want to do to get that
working is I can use the functionality
that model form gives me so first I need
to instantiate the form using the
request data so city form and then
requests posts and then form dot save
will both validate it and save it to the
database at the same time so form dot
save so now this should be it so if I
add another city in here I'll use my
original city Las Vegas then what I
expect to happen is after I click this
button that the page will refresh and I
will see four C's in here with Las Vegas
being one of the four so at City and
that's exactly what I see I see Las
Vegas has been added to the end of the
list if I add one more city Toronto we
see Toronto is now there so that's all I
wanted to do in this app of course
there's so much more you can do you can
make it to where you can delete cities
if you want you can add in more weather
information or anything that you can
think of for this app there are so many
different ways that you can modify it
and like I said I'll include the code
for this in the description below as
well so you can try it out yourself